here now with reaction is Fox News
contributor Jonathan Turley Jonathan
Turley we expected this appeal I I have
the writ of CT for the Supreme Court
right here in front of me and many of
the bases you and I discussed are the
arguments of the Republican party they
say section three of the 14th Amendment
is not self-executing and they say that
President Trump as a president does not
fall under the text of this amendment
what do you
think well it's a very strong appeal
it's frankly the moment that many of us
have been waiting for for uh for months
this dangerous theory has been
replicated throughout the country as
Challengers try to find a judge or a
court uh that will give Credence to this
Theory uh many of us believe that it's
fundamentally wrong from historical and
illegal perspective but they finally
found four justices in Colorado that
were willing to do this now that courted
seven democratically appointed justices
and three three of them refused to sign
on with this and said that it was
clearly wrong but they were able to eek
out a 43 win in Colorado that is now an
outlier you know you have the Michigan
Supreme Court following other courts in
refusing to disqualify the former
president so it is ripe for the Supreme
Court to review there's a conflict among
the states and there's a very weighty
issue here uh obviously uh for the
country
it is and you look over at Michigan one
of the big victories there and you
pointed this out on Twitter now known as
X that Democrats actually help to stop
Trump from being removed from the ballot
these are Judges justices appointed by
democrats right and I think that's
important to remind people because in
this age of Rage uh we often make
assumptions about people that we don't
agree with with and it's important to
note that this theory has been rejected
in various states by Democratic judges
judges appointed by Democratic Governors
or or judges that are in fact Democrats
who ran for office um they showed that
they could resist temptation that they
have greater falty to the Constitution
uh than they do their own views and own
political uh preferences so the question
now is
will the Supreme Court intervene I
believe it it will what's interesting
about this filing is it doesn't raise uh
the right to free speech and it does not
raise the factual determination that
that this was an Insurrection uh that
will be raised presumably in later
appeals but instead they're focusing on
the threshold issues of the removal of
this name from the ballot I think it's a
very strong
appeal professor cley I have just a
moment here but should the Supreme Court
take this and rule on this is this the
biggest case pertaining to a
presidential election since Bush
Vore yes and it's a very important uh
point to raise Bush V Gore was
destructive for the court in many
respects many of the justices spent
years trying to repair the divisions on
the court itself I think that the chief
justice is going to try to get a
unanimous decision here I hope that it
can speak with one voice and voice
should be to reject Colorado's decision
and to protect our Democratic Values to
show the public that the court itself is
divided ideologically but they remain
unified on these basic values that
Define
us would be a great day for democracy
indeed if it were 90 Professor Turley
thank you for your hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else